the massacre of 26 people in a Texas
church last Sunday is just the latest in
a recent series of mass shootings of the
5 deadliest shootings in modern US
history three have taken place in the
last two years and two in just the last
two months it has some suggesting that
mass killings can actually catch on like
an epidemic
the theory is examined in an online
article in the Atlantic we are joined by
the author of that article senior editor
Derek Thompson
Derek great to see you as always good
morning good morning talk to me about
how the approach is where there's a new
approach to look at mass killings almost
like diseases yeah it's really
interesting because you look at all
these killings in Orlando and Las Vegas
and and Texas and as you said there does
seem to be I think and if people who are
watching the news seem to feel like is
this accelerating and indeed there's
research that suggests it is there's a
2015 paper that says that mass diseases
or that these mass shootings can spread
like diseases essentially through the
vector of mass media typically diseases
spread between individuals these are
diseases however that spread through
mass media you have certain men
throughout the country and they do tend
to be men who essentially have an itch
are susceptible to this kind of
oppressive self aggrandizement they're
frustrated in some way they want to
destroy the people's lives because of it
and they see this example on the news
and they say I can do the same thing and
I can reach that same level of Fame the
word you uses infect potential new
murderers yeah it's a very strong word
it is and to a certain extent you can
think of it as infectious you can think
of it as a sort of copycat effect yeah
and because it's it's spreading through
broadcast it might be similar to the
same way that people have already shown
that suicide for example has this
broadcast effect that when there's a a
very public suicide that you can have a
spate that clusters around that you can
have similar effects when it comes to
all sorts of of health behaviors they've
shown that both positive and negative
health behaviors can sort of cluster a
lot like diseases so I think we're just
beginning to learn that all sorts of
behaviors both positive and negative can
have a kind of contagion effect and it's
really important for the media to study
it so that we know how to report these
events that we don't accidentally
these question affects themselves as far
as mass killings those who seem most
susceptible to it are men of a certain
kind you talk about men who are looking
for grandiose aspirations and they also
Harbor petty grievances yeah that's more
about that well you think about the
descriptors of these men every single
time this happens it's always loner it's
someone who wasn't well-known someone
who is perceived as an outcast it's
never someone who's who sort of wrapped
up in the social fabric and so somewhat
ironically like most diseases spread
because you're wrapped up in the social
fabric you're close to people who are
sick and that's what infects you but the
reason this sort of disease is so
interesting is that because it spreads
through broadcast it can find people who
are alone who are less likely to be
infected by any literal virus that may
be more likely to be infected by the
virus of this sort of self
aggrandizement that says you're out
there you're frustrated you're sad here
is a way to possibly be good to you
there's an interesting point you also
make referring to that 2015 study that
Arizona State University did that
there's actually no significant
association between the rate of mass
shootings and the prevalence of mental
illness in the state that's right I do
think that mental illness is a bit of a
canard here there's been a lot of
research that essentially says very
simply that where there are more guns
there are more gun deaths and gun deaths
don't just include mass killings don't
just include homicides also include
accidental child firearm deaths the u.s.
has 5% of the industrial world's
children and 90% of the industrial
world's accidental firearms death
involving children I mean the the
explanation there is not that our
children are 15 times more mentally
unhealthy it's that they are simply
surrounded by weapons that they don't
know how to use well this is gonna
prompt a very serious debate as it
always does about guns but also the ways
in which we study the contagion of mass
shootings Derek Thompson always good to
see you thanks for your time thank you